hey youtubers is Charlie so James gun
dropped the bomb recently said that he'd
been offered DC films in the Justice
League universe post Christopher Nolan
so there's gonna be a breakdown of that
he also talked about DC films that he
was interested in doing
he didn't confirm exactly when he was
offered this DC movie like one of this
is all taking place but this tweet
offers like a little clarification you
know it might have been after guardians
of the galaxy putting it well past the
time when they've already started
putting Batman V Superman in motion as
well as Suicide Squad so I don't think
it was those films and because James gut
is so good at working with misfit
characters I really feel like it would
be Green Lantern's that was probably the
movie that he was offered because there
was such a stigma attached to the movie
after it bombed in 2011 one of the big
reasons why it has remained off of DC's
big promotional schedule is because it's
so far off in so separated from what's
going on in the Justice League movies
right now
but it is connected to Justice League
we'll see how Jordan in other Green
Lantern's with Justice League eventually
it's just that in addition to that movie
being really hard to nail for any
director you have like the added baggage
of what happened with it in 2011 so they
just want to put some distance between
that so I think considering the James
Gunn would have been making guardians of
the galaxy trilogy like if that movie
blew up and then they're like oh my god
look at what he did with these misfit
characters that nobody cared about
before he made everybody care about them
and it almost made a billion dollars
okay we need to have him do this for
some of our characters but he's probably
gonna make a trilogy so that's why Green
Lantern's was probably so far off they
just wanted to help people forget about
the last movie and give him time to make
his guardians of the galaxy trilogy the
third guardians movie hasn't come out
yet but I would expect it within about
two years of the release of the second
guardians movie which is next year 2017
so sometime in 2019 or 2020 we'll see
that third Guardians movie Marvel's
probably going to shuffle the release
dates of a couple films and phase four
just based on the success of a lot of
the new characters movies in Phase three
like we have Doctor Strange
we have black panther we have Captain
Marvel if some of those movies really
blow up like buh way bigger or do way
worse than they expect then they'll just
shuffle
dates a little bit but as sensational as
all this sounds like oh my god the idea
of James Gunn directing a DC film that's
crazy I would love to see James Gunn's
take on DC characters you have to
remember that there's just like a
certain small group of Directors in
Hollywood that are just like a game
anything that they touch turns into an
awesome movie like Christopher Nolan is
the best example of that he came out of
the Dark Knight trilogy being able to do
anything that he wanted one of the most
powerful directors in Hollywood so when
you have repeat big giant hits like it
seems James Gunn is going to have with
guardians of the galaxy to like with the
big guardians franchise you get a lot
more people just banging on your door
asking for help because everybody wants
a franchise every studio wants the
regularity of profits that franchise
brings so if you're an amazing director
who can tell really amazing stories with
any group of misfit characters you're
just like the hot girl in high school
everybody wants to go out with you so
this is really a testament to James Gunn
being super awesome but then he went on
to say that obviously he declined
because he's too busy with guardians in
the characters that they offered him
which may or may not have been Green
Lantern's just weren't that interesting
to him the characters that he talks
about being really interested in like
Swamp Thing Shazam
metal men they're all really like misfit
characters that aren't super popular
like you have Batman Superman there are
good examples of the most popular
characters everybody wants to write a
Batman story James Gunn seems to be more
interested in the really weird
characters that nobody cares about
so naturally DC probably isn't as
excited to make one of those movies like
they want to make the really big
character movies first which is a
totally normal thing but they do have a
release schedule that they want to hit
so based on the time the DC wanted to
make this movie like the release date
they wanted to hit in the time the James
gun had available and the characters
they were offering he said that he had
to decline but I do like I just love the
idea of a James Gunn Swamp Thing movie
or even like Metal Men Metal Men are a
super deep cut but let me know in the
comments which movie do you think that
he was offered do you think it was Green
Lanterns or do you think that it was
something else do you think it was like
a single character movie I just feel
like it was a big ensemble team up movie
and which
would you want to see James gonna do if
he were to do a DC movie
I feel like Swamp Thing everybody wants
a Swamp Thing movie so if that's gonna
be the one we do then that would be the
one I would watch James Gunn to do but
just to explain why I don't think that
he was offered Justice League or some of
the more recent felt like the films that
are coming out really soon
I feel like Zack Snyder had already been
hired to do Man of Steel in his part of
the moderate success of that film he was
offered Batman V Superman they wanted to
get the ball rolling because that
started out as a Superman sequel but
then kind of got turned into a Batman
movie with Superman in it in the plant
sprawled into the big Justice League ten
film release schedule so all that
happened after Man of Steel had come out
so their plans changed really quickly
and obviously they've already changed
again because of all the stuff that's
going behind the scenes with Geoff Johns
becoming the new Kevin Feige of DC films
but they already had this very clear
vision of what they wanted with Batman V
Superman Justice League Suicide Squad
was kind of like this own thing off by
itself and because David Ayer only had
about six weeks to work on the Suicide
Squad script I feel like that you know
there's not enough time for that to have
worked out for James Gunn to have been
offered it after guardians of the galaxy
like he was pretty much guaranteed to be
working on the guardians sequel when
they were starting work on Suicide Squad
so that's why I feel like Justice League
was always gonna be a Zack Snyder film
although it is really interesting to
think about James Gunn directing a
Justice League movie but what's gonna
happen next is in the Marvel verse
they've talked about Punisher Season one
that Netflix looks like it's a reveal
that it's coming out in 2017 so I'll be
doing a video about that next so be sure
to subscribe to get that congratulations
to the DC giveaway winner Joshua or
Rilla you win a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts now
I know we're talking about James Gunn
who's Marvel but technically this is a
DC video but all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video they like my next DC video
will probably be flash season 3 but my
next video today will be punished or
season 1 so that should post later
tonight what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my guardians
of the galaxy 2 trailer breakdown from
Comic Con and you can click here to
learn all about Henry cobbles black
Superman costume and Justice League
thank you so much for watching everybody
sigh five I'll see you guys tonight